[Musique]
il va y avoir plein de questions ce soir
et la première question c'est est un
tweet c'est un téléspectateur qui nous
demandent d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien
avoir le nom des tweets au sein qui
envoie s'il vous plaît merci en régie je
reviens vers le nom des personnes qui
envoient l'aller les questions oui on
peut pas parce que ces lignes on dit que
l'on se faire lâcher sur twitter non ils
ont le messie au fait si vous mettez les
noms n'y a pas qu'ils vont se relâcher
si le maître il faut le mettre
donc vous mettez les non merci cap ou
bep fait ce qu on dit merci aux
catacombes et toi qui n'est pas langue
de bois dit nous qui parle le plus de
cyril dans son dos alors on parle bien
des gens l'équipe
ah bah oui ben au nom de ma mère
pourrait vous dire ce qu'on dise vous
dans le paf
alors ça c'est marrant ça c'est marrant
il va pas mariah va pas se marrer
beaucoup on va commencer dans l'équipe
globalement celui qui parle le plus dans
votre dos ouais c'est mathieu doom
attendait jeu mais un jeu mais je mets
et je mets un bémol
oui je mets un bémol quand ils râlent
généralement il le fait aussi devant
vous et c'est celui qu'il ouvre plus
devant vous ouais il dit les choses
après celle qui parfois peut se rebeller
mais qui ne dit pas devant vous c'est
valérie après un petit peu de temps en
temps elle est un peu agacé par
certaines choses par certains tournages
par à douala par à la façon de
travailler tout ça voilà
mais c'est ça par contre ça n'est jamais
méchant ça n'est jamais c'est toujours
bienveillants à part parfois mathieu
mais après les autres non il ne parle
pas dans votre dos j'ai envie de calais
animateurs qui parle le plus dans mon
dos dans le paf
globalement beaucoup de gens parlent de
vous dans le fax et à que vous êtes pour
eux un avenir et ils comprennent pas et
je suis le premier à avoir mal parlé de
vous parce que je vous connaissais pas
est en fait le peuple sait que vous êtes
tellement hors norme que l'on s'imagine
des tas de choses il ya un fantasme il
ce qui se crée autour de vous on entende
10 millions de choses et vous êtes à
correctement à chaque fois vous et aller
vers les gens qui ne vous met pas et
vous saviez très bien généralement ces
gens là vous êtes rapprocher d'eux comme
christophe dechavanne paris
jean-christophe toujours défendu quand
vous l'attaquez après il y en ad'autres
est un peu plus compliquée à elle
maintenant même sac mais mais
globalement
oui vous vous intriguer vous intriguer
et vous agacer donc forcément on parle
de vous alors comme mathieu parle devant
vous prétendument je vais juste vous
citer une petite phrase qu'il a
prononcée
vous allez sans doute la connaître
c'était il ya trois semaines le petit
tunisien m'a envoyé un sms il hier soir
j'ai pas répondu j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
de ce renard s'il va se calmer tout seul
ok je pense que c'est vrai ou alors
évidemment la sortie de son contexte et
bien évidemment c'est avec humour car on
sait que je fais aussi je pratique aussi
ça d'humour voilà elle d'abord sympa et
l'inde là où je suis je suis pas content
de ce que tu dit benjamin ça mais sympa
ce projet pas content c'est que dans le
dos c'est faux non mais les quelques la
dj disse étudie derrière je veux redire
à d'accord tu n'as les quelques pions ou
général et vous comprenez un petit peu
le vieux merville avait aimé sa carence
part dans le dos de quand j'ai eu un
truc à cause des pollutions bal avec
vous ça commence souvent par dans le
doigt